[Musique]
ali tounkara bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors au moins 60
civils
on le disait depuis dimanche dans
l'ouest du niger cela fait 130 morts en
dix jours comment on peut expliquer
cette recrudescence d'attaqués ces
derniers jours c'est vrai que quand on
regarde le niger dès décembre 2020
aujourd'hui et c'est ce côté civil on a
réussi à 1367 aux victimes un seulement
10 huile un quad et seulement à ce stade
trois grandes hypothèses pourraient être
avancées la première est parti beaucoup
plus plausible
on sait que boko haram et les tests
lamic font l'objet justement à des
attaques staff émeutière dans les
frontières vitaux d'adam les partis dit
de la frontière je suis peiné ces
différentes localités aujourd'hui termes
pourquoi la sécurité au niger sont comme
des localités qui ont connu dans les
années 90 des les médications six
socialistes d'un clairement cette
incursion de beaucoup à moi de l'état
islamique expliquer ces attaques sont
dirigées contre les populations civiles
à la deuxième hypothèse qui n'est pas
non plus à négliger consistait aussi
effectivement à les questions et tous se
confient aux locaux et qu'il estime le
quotidien des populations sont quand
même les populations essentiellement
nomades
lesquels ne m'en disent non à provoquer
et pas mal de tension aujourd'hui en dhr
avec les élèves rdc pratique du talent
des trois frontières donc aujourd'hui
nous assistons si vous voulez à une
recrudescence de ce conflit
communautaire est lesquels conflit
communautaire finiront malheureusement
pas vous basculez belle ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'une épilation
communautaire la tripoter ce terrain il
faut le rappeler par votre introduction
le paysan bazinet carrément des nominés
etiquetté si vous voulez être à
l'origine d'un certain nombre de déçus
vivement dans les contextes au niger
certains voient dans ces attaques
virtuelles ces derniers temps en 3d
certaines banques aux trafiquants qui ne
seraient pas d'accord avec une
gouvernance orthodoxe promis par le
nouveau résident donc en somme sommes
nous en face d'eux des zecs 13 grid les
quelques tribunaux font l'objet les
connexions avec des narcotraficants de
l'état islamique de boko haram est même
tout en suscitant en proposant un
habillage communautaire ou
hagiographiques à des tensions
effectivement qui sont antérieurs à ces
attaques puissantes
ça pourrait être un test une provocation
pour voir finalement là la réaction du
nouveau président bazoum selon vous
après 50 quand même c'est les
différentes localités aujourd'hui un pur
à l'insécurité d'agadez en passant par
ces localités telles que tu as choix et
même dix façons de localités entre
autres on s'est rapidement que nous
avons en face des narcotrafiquants
lesquels trafic clairement et un ancrage
communautaire donc certaines communautés
qui se sentait menacé par la vue ni les
mêmes bases où il s'est réveillé ce à
quoi une hypothèse qui est esquivée
scaramouche pénal mais pas que le plus
important progrès aussi les attaques
récentes au manu clément eut notamment
dans le service d'à sono la région de
gao au mali sont des localités qui font
qu'ils sont son talent hier au niger
quelle localité entre hébergent ou en
tout cas à vite un nombre important des
ex rebelles maliet lesquels localité
aujourd'hui sont considérés comme les
piliers de l'état me donne à 100 cette
interconnexion entre les entrepreneurs
de la violence côté mali côté niger et
au burkina
malheureusement structurer davantage le
pourquoi les ces différentes victoires
aux jo de l'emporter parce que nous
pratiquons violents impliqués dans les
trafics
là les narcotrafics tout en ayant aussi
une certaine légitimité
les deux communautés sont ses références
et communautaires religieux géographie
qui sont brandis par cette africa est
passé tout près du coup violent il
justement mohamed bazoum est ce que il
va agir est ce qu il a les moyens d'agir
en tout cas dans la région du niger pour
lutter contre ces violences conscient
qu'un manque aujourd'hui les jeunes ne
pas laisser le pays qu'elle est efficace
soins quand ce groupe est à découvrir à
la france il ya plus les certains waro
mittal cela est quand même clairement
présente dans les selles et simon niger
à partir de 2015 2016 avec la le person
barkan
laquelle opération elle permet à
certains égards aux différences d'armes
israéliennes non seulement de se
renforcer en termes de capacités
opérationnelles mais dans le même temps
à nous fournir l'équipement aussi des
chansons assez là aussi focalisé sur la
plaie
la force conjointe de 2,5 c'est là où on
a annoncé aux magies semer du g5 dès
maintenant au tchad
l'envoi de 1000 descente qui aliène tout
cela pourrait être perçu par ne vous
prends des coups violents comme en
éliminant ce quant à leur efficacité et
une menace quant à l'abus et dans dans
le monde pendant france si vous voulez
détection important également le fait
que des tout petits aliens dans son
camion stationné aujourd'hui au niger
d'alimenter à la force une dame
française
et comme tout aussi l'armée régulière
nigérienne la manipuler cette présence
massive et des amis en présence les
groupes locaux arrivent au père parce
que il bénéficie incontestablement
laissé soutien du thé loire la
protection important pour le paysan
bâtiment aujourd'hui d'aller au delà du
de toutes les considérations
communautaire d'aller au delà
le toucher que tu es le portion
aujourd'hui justement d'être c'est le
pot est nous qui se pose est une
communauté ou bâtiments duo français et
il est comme une installation sa méthode
en tant que chef suprême des armées
nigérianes de faire en sorte que les
attentes qu'on me julien quand avons
fait la demande de sécurité soient
comblés de manière efficace et surtout
pertinentes et et peut-être pour
conclure est ce que ces attaques
meurtrières ne sont pas finalement aussi
les conséquences de l'inaction du
président issoufou qui qui a précédé à
abu ahmed bazoum suffit il a quand même
apporté un stand de réponse notamment
dans les régions de diffa mondes et
tillabéry un thème de ce soit les
possibilités ou même des actions qu'on
pourrait qualifier développementiste
mais fondamentalement elle était chantée
je pense qu'ils sont vu proposer par les
eaux mais s'il y en a en l'occurrence
nigérienne au son et le cosmologiste
sont limitées dans le temps
le militaire à monter quand même ses
limites et celles ci prennent aux yeux
de ces différentes situations de
conflits qualité elles sont des
situations qui est la gouvernance locale
sur les situations qui importe combien
et une certaine élite militaire c'est le
comble donc je pense que nous on ne peut
pas apporter des solutions durables à
dépendre aussi structurant à monsieur
réponse il est de la responsabilité
aujourd'hui tu pourrais tu es nigérienne
de faire en sorte que les différentes
dire quand une population soit
satisfaite justement avec une certaine
orthodoxie avec une certaine utilité
mais malheureusement l'impression qu'ils
donnent aujourd'hui l'important n'est
plus rien c'est d'avoir une élite
politique et du militaire qui s'est
clairement inversée pas de pratiques
collectives ou les différentes aides qui
sont proposées par les états partenaires
ou même dans les différentes vont
également sondés font malheureusement
qui n'arrivent pas à destination
vous pouvez relire le parti politique
donc il est extrêmement important
aujourd'hui que le président martelly à
l'ivg soit une gouvernance vertueuse
faire en sorte le me gêne profonde il se
sentait l'état santé malheureusement
c'est cette absence d n'était et tulle
expliquer une telle furieusement à celui
situé à l'état ce rentable dans la
dépendance de la justice même l'instant
d'instaurer cette chercheuse ballades
telles que l'accès à l'eau potable
même la mobilité des populations
notamment google merci beaucoup ali
tounkara d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans la matinale d'ayrté france je le
rappelle vous êtes directeur fondateur
du centre des études sécuritaires et
stratégiques au sahel
vous êtes à bamako